la joue et qu'on revienne au cours du
journal poursuivre ensuite savait que
d'habitude nous avons ici une séquence
ce tous les jours qui s'appelle le crime
c'est une séquence dans laquelle on a
plutôt la volonté d'assaisonner les
clients que nous recevons puisque nous
sommes pas d'accord ou que des questions
se proposa propres propos de leurs
actions et bien vous allez voir
aujourd'hui c'est une toute autre
manière d'interroger ses clients que
nous allons vous présenter c'est tout à
fait le contraire ça donne parfois des
résultats assez curieux vous allez le
voir
oui avez-vous conscience du fait que
vous avez un petit peu renouvelé même
complètement renouvelé le studio
télévisée au côté vous êtes bien mon
cher confrère mais j'ai pas du tout
renouveler et s'il faut nous a quand
même su se relancer avant moi l'ont fait
mieux que moi non mais quand même vous
avez une précision dans vos informations
que n'ont pas les autres que vous avez
un peu non non je suis je suis très
franc je m'inspire par exemple de
l'exemple jean-michel des jeunes qui a
été un très bon présentateur qui est un
peu de ma génération et c'est vrai qu'il
lui même a renouvelé un petit peu les
choses
vous ne pensez pas que votre bouquet
physique vous avez dans votre
présentation vous êtes gentils de
l'encré je crois vraiment que j'ai
beaucoup de progrès à faire de ce côté
là donc ma faim de par quand même vous
avez comme une réussite et
intellectuelles et physiques
chacun avait conscience est gentil
gentil j'espère quand même quel plus
intellectuel que physique mais ça ne
nous gêne pas vis-à-vis des autres
présentateurs je dis respect de
supériorité qui est assez dingue et du
loc'h wydad est moche et moi je ne veux
pas citer liban et l'inde et elle
aimerait bien enfin je crois que c'est
pas l'essentiel du débat ce n'est pas
l'essentiel que c'est très important
opérateur ne vous avez conscience comme
de la qualité est ce que c'est gênant
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de vos paires si
intelligent et si bon absolument
alors très franchement non parce que je
navigue dans un monde plus que vous
connaissez bien qu'ils aient fait de
genre à peu près de l'autre style dire
tout ça c'est bon on est tous assez
intelligent et passionné de l'aide c'est
une longue préparation avant de
présenter le journal lui de vous
regarder dans la glace tous les matins
ensuite septembre jour là il faut se
maquiller il faut se faire beau et faut
se mettre une cravate que j'ai pas
aujourd'hui pardon c'est sûr mais c'est
vraiment là tout est parti de là espère
que comme très important parce que ça
démontre une certaine force de caractère
sans doute aussi nationaux style de vie
oui alors écoutez de ce côté-là non
franchement c'est pour moi c'est
vraiment accessoire c'est l'écumé des
choses
lyannaj doper les traits vous êtes au
crible aujourd'hui parce que